this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 73 with Michael Charles sitting
across from me
and me chocolate so I was at a jiu jitsu
tournament recently
and I was coaching one of our students
who's a blue Belch
and she wrestled in high school she has
a good background in jiu jitsu
she might be related to me
uh so she she did um
started off the day you know we had a
bunch of tea a bunch of people from
Victory there about the the tournament
started off with
ghee she did ghee she did great she she
won
um gold in that one and then in nogi
which she wrestled in high school so
what are you thinking yeah you're
thinking that's kind of our you know her
a a-o and anyways she lost her for you
she's going against a really really good
a bunch of really good girls I mean a
blue belt right now like
and actually no geese so some of these
girls are not blue belt some of them
maybe purple belts or whatever I don't
necessarily know what these uh other
women were
but she lost her first match and so she
got done and you know she got another
match coming up and
before she started her next match I gave
it all the time you know because the
last thing you do like when someone
walks off after losing is immediately
just go into critique mode because that
ain't gonna land
especially with my daughter so
you know I just didn't say anything you
know let her chill and then when she's
getting ready like she kind of gave me a
look like what do you got you know what
should I do and I was like cool that's
it like permission to speak
and so I told her uh I just said hey
don't accept anything
and she knew what I was talking about
she knew that in the previous match
which was a tough match she lost two to
zero but she accepted some things you
know
and she knew what I was talking about
and
it happens
it happens in Jiu Jitsu and it happens
in
in life
so
and she actually won the match where she
didn't accept anything she she won that
next match and all good but
so like rolling with Dean if I roll with
Dean list
who's a world champion guy really good
like naturally incredibly gifted um Jiu
Jitsu player if I accept if I go into
the on the map I'm like oh you know no
big deal if he does this no big deal I'm
gonna get murdered you have to go in
when I train with Dean most days there's
some days if he's having a horrible day
maybe I can accept a little bit but if I
if I want to go in there and actually do
well I can't accept anything yeah think
about that I cannot accept anything I
can't accept it I have to fight
everything
and if I accept I get I get murdered
okay so if you're going look and if
you're going with someone that's better
than you this is kind of like what you
have to do especially if someone has a
tight game right sometimes a tight game
and you accept you they're gonna they're
gonna destroy you
here's another thing like I say you
should never voluntarily let someone
close their guard on you there's another
thing that people get used to accepting
right and look is there a time for it
yes there is but most of the time you
don't accept someone to do that don't
let them do it don't accept it
you have to watch out for that don't
accept the takedown that was I had
Jeremy Stevens
UFC it was the first fight where he had
moved out here to San Diego to train
and he was fighting Rafael dosanos okay
and Jeremy Stevens is a freaking awesome
guy and he's from Iowa you know he
wrestled in high school
but his Jujitsu this is when he first
got here this is
probably 10 years ago
something like that it's a long it's
maybe even more than 10 years he's
saying more than 10 years ago he did not
know Jiu Jitsu he was an actual white
belt in Jiu Jitsu like an actual like
white belt in Jiu Jitsu and he's
fighting hafio dosanos who's a world you
know World beater in Jiu Jitsu a black
belt in jiu jitsu
and I and so Jeremy's fight
I think the fight was in Chicago I think
and we're getting ready you can't teach
someone you we have whatever five weeks
to get him ready you can't teach him
when Jiu Jitsu in five weeks show them a
couple basic things you can't teach them
Jiu Jitsu you can't you can't teach
someone to survive against a black belt
on the mats in five weeks you cannot do
it
so
I was like listen you cannot get taken
down do not accept the takedown at all
ever against this guy if you if he takes
you down you're gonna
can die
sure
and
he went in there
and dude this guy was trying to take him
down and look Jeremy had like high
school level wrestling but more
important he had the mindset he was not
going to accept the takedown it wasn't
he I said Hey listen when if you start
getting taken down before you hit the
ground you're getting back up you're
getting away from him you fight like
you're gonna die if you go down and
that's what he did and in the third
round he knocked dos anjos into freaking
next year
this is one of them it's a it's a
highlight it's a highlight
all-time highlight of UFC is his
uppercut from
the depths of hell
and blue dos annuals Consciousness out
of the stadium
in the third round after fighting off
takedowns just just would not accept it
so
this happens in real life as well
uh
we allow things to happen that we should
not accept
we should not accept we allow ourselves
to get out of shape you see people like
that yeah you didn't get out of shape
overnight you accepted it day after day
after day after day
we let ourselves get into bad financial
situations
we accept it a little bit at a time I'll
just put this on credit I'll just get
another credit card we that's what we do
we accept doing a job or do or living a
life that we really don't want to live
and what I'm saying is do not accept
that
and I'm not telling you to be rash I'm
not telling you to go to work tomorrow
and quit your job I'm not telling you to
starve yourself if you're if you're fat
right now or you're out of shape
but I'm telling you don't accept it
figure a way out
it doesn't need to be rational let me
give an example
you ever seen the movie Shawshank
Redemption yes sir okay
he's not accepting his fate and it take
how long does it take him in that movie
to get out of prison it's like 10 years
right I think it was like 19. 19 years
bro he's he's plotting he doesn't accept
it
everyone else in that movie accepts it
accepts it to the point that when they
get out they don't want to be out that's
how much they accept their fate
so that's what I'm saying
don't there's things in life where you
cannot accept them and if you accept
them a little bit you lose everything
now look
I got it since we're talking to you just
a little bit like Jeff Glover has a way
of like over accepting things that works
for him right like he he you know will
let someone someone's gonna take his
back he'll roll into it and roll right
through it right
and you can do that too I've done that
in my life it's something that I don't
really want to do but I just go for it I
go all like when I went to college I
didn't want to go to college I just went
I just went all in and acted like crazy
ecologists did everything just went for
it
so that was my way of winning in a
situation that I didn't want to be and I
was like okay you know what if I'm in
the situation I don't like I'm gonna I'm
gonna have fun winning at it
I I went into it
but
that's the thing to do
um and as much as I look and there's
there's obviously a contradiction here I
talk all the time about being flexible
and taking the indirect approach
and
that that's that's the answer right most
of the time
but when it comes to your life from a
strategic perspective
strategic perspective when you look at
your whole life
or you look at certain situations on the
Jiu Jitsu matter you look at certain
situations at work
from a strategic perspective
look you can play the games you can be
flexible you can take the indirect
approach but make sure that you're not
accepting things that you don't truly
want to accept
and find a way out even if it takes 19
years start today
that's what I got for you
that's that's funny you've mentioned
Jeff Glover yeah his way because he is
it's technically
a bigger like picture more like a more
profound level of not accepting it it's
more like I'm gonna accept it for a
greater
unacceptance you know so it's almost
like and if you apply it like to outside
of Jiu Jitsu it's like hey if you see
little things creeping in little things
that you don't want creeping in whether
it be complacency or whatever workouts
you know a lot of times like you're
about to do a workout or something and
you're like oh shoot oh frick I gotta
finish this thing is important so I'm
gonna finish it and you're like oh my
gosh I had an hour to work out and I
only have 45 minutes and then some
people like I'll just do it tomorrow
right or even 30 minutes they'll be like
ah okay I'll do it we'll be like no no
jump in there and you better do
everything you can kind of a thing right
but Jeff Glover is like okay I'm not
gonna work out today but I'm gonna make
it so whatever I do in that 30 minutes
is gonna be like oh dang I'm at the end
of like whatever day that is or whatever
week or whatever you're gonna be kind of
glad you did this other thing rather
than the workout almost like my lack of
time for the workout kind of provided
this thing that I figured out right then
and there is is going to be even more
beneficial yeah I was going to say like
maybe you're in a job that you don't
like
so then you're like you know what I'm
gonna get so good at this that I can get
promoted and not have to do it anymore
exactly right or just pay attention to
other things so by not accepting it
you're like I don't accept this position
I'm in I'm gonna work so hard at it that
I get out of it yeah and just say yeah
just that little mind shift or whatever
will like make you go in a completely
different direction and it kind of helps
your attitude two men like the your
whole College thing and the paperwork
story that you always tell or whatever
man if you can really like Embrace that
or whatever you can be because at the
end of doing paperwork or at the end of
doing college or whatever you're kind of
like you kind of killed college is a
good thing so like if you want to do
your garage I don't know I'm thinking of
my life so it's like all the garage like
needs some clearing out you know but I'm
not gonna do that kind of stuff you know
meanwhile it just gets more and you know
stuff that comes in I'm like all right
I'll get the lab put in the garage so
it's just getting worse and worse if I
was like you know what no I'm gonna
embrace it super hard I'm gonna go hard
with the garage when it's done you're
gonna be way happier see what I'm saying
yeah so it's almost like if I just
accept okay well I guess we're not using
the garage anymore yeah exactly right
and then boom not only did you more
enjoy something that you didn't
before
the garage is done so I'm saying can be
your whole life
I like it I like it all right let's get
some question first question chocolate
huge fan podcast helped me tremendously
throughout the last few years I'm 29
years old
and I want to be
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then
you mobilized
Underground